i think most youtubers when you reach a  certain size you start planning videos  backwards so when you think about a  video of thinking about thumbnail title  would people click on it and then from  there you're like okay what's the  content going to be like is it engaging  is it delivering value will people  finish that video thinking whoa i like  this guy and then at that point then  you're thinking you take a step further  back it's like okay what's the storyline  what's the subplot how are you keeping  people throughout that video engaged and  then you work all the way back and then  that's the point where you've got your  content you know what your next step is  the trigger point is either an idea i've  had embedded  or some past video that did really well  that people really enjoyed and they're  like can we have a part two yeah or  something someone else has done that i  think that's a really interesting idea  what if i applied it to phones or you  know gadgets or whatever